l'Alsace à l'honneur au gymnase Chantal
Mauduit de Magny-les-Hameaux pour cette
36e édition du Téléthon et cette année
la commune a été choisie pour être le
village du secteur est dans les Yvelines
une fierté pour l'association objective
Téléthon manicois qui existe depuis 15
ans
83 par habitant
c'est un beau chiffre parce qu'on est un
euro 13 à Paris on en est très très fier
et cette fierté fait que nous sommes
aujourd'hui
village Téléthon reconnu donc dans ce
qui est fait ici à Magny-les-Hameaux au
programme de nombreuses animations
baskets coloriage et course sportive
aujourd'hui on a fait un une course
itinérante avec plus de 30 je ne sais
pas pompiers qui ont couru 13 km avec un
jeune une jeune personne handicapée qui
a 10 ans qui s'appelle Enzo et donc
voilà donc c'est ce sont ces jeunes qui
ont porté ce projet qui ont porté Enzo
pendant toute la course et cette année
nous brousse la gagnante de The Voice
2022 était la marraine du Téléthon Mani
quoi défends cette cause pour la science
parce que c'est important ça peut
arriver à tout le monde et c'est une
cause très importante je pense qu'on a
tous eu quelqu'un dans notre famille
atteinte d'une maladie et c'est très
compliqué donc c'est pour ça que je
soutiens cette cause aujourd'hui
[Musique]
j'ai choisi une chanson qui s'appelle
rise up et c'est l'histoire d'une d'un
couple
il y a un monsieur qui est en fauteuil
roulant qui a une maladie et sa femme
l'aide à gravir les montagnes en fait
avec lui et je trouvais que c'est une
chanson d'espoir et pour le Téléthon
c'est quand même important de de passer
un message d'espoir aux gens direction
Les Clayes-sous-Bois une autre célébrité
était présente pour soutenir la cause il
est important dans les moments que l'on
vit de venir soutenir d'aider
d'encourager quelque part à tous les
bénévoles qui qui organisent
cette manifestation je trouve ça génial
de participer je suis très fier d'être
leurs parents au total
683401 euros ont été récoltés dans les
Yvelines un chiffre qui tend à évoluer
mais qui est tout de même en baisse par
rapport à l'année dernière ou 712000
euros avait été récolté
ressenti il y a le le problème actuel il
y a eu moins de ventes à mon avis il y a
moins de ventes dans les temps de tenu
par les bénévoles et si vous souhaitez
faire un don vous pouvez toujours le
faire jusqu'au vendredi 9 décembre